ja also nochmal wir kommen von meiner
seite her heute geht es um das thema
virtuelle leer und lernräume was hat es
damit auf sich ich will untersuchen was
sind virtuelle und lernräume und was
sollen sie also nicht nur eine
beschreibung sondern auch eine wertung
in dieser art soll der vortrag ablaufen
was habe ich vor der vortrag ich werde
erst ihnen was sagen zum inhalt also ich
werde jetzt die frage untersuchen was
sind virtuelle realitäten weil es geht
ja um die virtuellen leer und leerräume
dann werde ich ihnen vorstellen was es
mit der raum logik virtueller realität
auf sich hat also wie wir die
räumlichkeit denken müssen die virtuelle
realität zu grunde liegt oder wie
virtuelle realität unsere raum logik
verändert oder transformiert dann werde
ich noch was sagen zur didaktik raumes
das ist ja die frage auch dieses
gesamten zum postens neuen funktionen
kommen hinzu wenn wir es jetzt nicht mit
dem physischen raum zu tun haben soll
mit einem virtuellen raum dazu wir
müssen erst wissen dass ein virtueller
raum ist und zum schluss werde ich ein
paar anwendungsbeispiele vorstellen die
aus meiner eigenen praxis entspringen
von denen ich glaube dass sie den
virtuellen raum didaktisch gut ausnutzen
so zum ersten punkt was ist virtuelle
realität
ich habe da so meine eigene thesen dazu
die möchte ich ihn einfach mal
vorstellen die wird die frage nach
virtuelle realität ist wie ich sie
verstehe keine triviale frage weil wird
realität in meinen augen wie ich noch
begründen möchte nicht dasselbe ist die
simulation häufig denkt man wenn man
virtuelle realität hört das ist sowas da
habe ich so eine brille auf und werdet
dann in eine illusion einbezogen das
kann sehr stimulierend sein man spricht
er von immersion als ich werde wirklich
einbezogen in diese simulation ich
verwechsle vielleicht sogar
meine jetzige physische realität mit der
simulation dennoch glaube ich ist das
nicht das richtige verständnis von
virtueller realität weil es die
potenziale von virtuelle realität
unterschätzt wenn es nur als simulation
aufgefasst wird
deswegen möchte ich die these betreten
virtuelle realitäten sind genau so real
wie andere realitäten
jetzt muss man sich natürlich fragen was
sind realitäten und der realitäten
verstehe ich räume jetzt auch ganz vage
gesprochen ganz offen gesprochen die
eine offenheit für kausale wirksamkeit
also es geht immer um wirksamkeit
realität ist eine form von wirksamkeit
aber auch von kausalität und auch
virtuelle realitäten die jetzt nicht
physisch gebunden sind die erlauben eine
form von kausalität als von wirksamkeit
und nächster punkt ist virtuelle
realitäten besitzen einen simulation
aspekt also sowas wie virtual reality
wenn wir die pläne auf haben das aber
nicht das einzige
sie besitzen auch noch einen fiktionalen
oder fiktiven als beck weil wir wie ich
gleich noch zeigen werden uns in
virtuellen realitäten von unserem
vorbild der physischen realität weiter
entfernt als es bloß simulationen tun
beispiel für digitale wird für virtuelle
realitäten ich sage dass gegen digitale
virtuelle realitäten weil es gibt auch
virtuelle realitäten die nicht digital
realisiert sind
man muss da nur an geldscheine denken
herkömmliches geld währungen
die sind auch eine form von virtualität
weil sein geld scheint dieses papier
natürlich nicht an sich den wert hat der
auf ihnen steht ein 50 euro schein ist
nicht als physisches phänomen 50 euro
wert der ist vielleicht werd jetzt
physisch gesehen vielleicht ein euro
oder 50 cent ich weiß es nicht genau
aber er hat einen virtuellen wert und
dieser wert 50 euro der is eben genau so
real wie wenn das papier selbst 50 euro
wert wäre
und daran sieht man virtualität ist
nicht was was hier
bei der digitalisierung epoche haben ist
ein virtualität war immer schon im spiel
deswegen sagen auch manche forscher es
hat eine längere bloodline als nur die
digitale digital object jetzt geben aber
zu den digitalen virtuellen objekten
da haben wir bitcoins das ist ganz klar
die sind nicht mehr auf einem träger
papier wie zb euro scheine die sind
völlig losgelöst von der physischen
realität dann haben wir den blauen casio
dem online rollenspiel runes teppich
zeigte den gleich noch also es geht um
gegenstände in rollenspielen die
natürlich auch nicht physisch realisiert
sind wir haben auch so banale dinge wie
online prüfungen die virtuelle realität
bedeuten
wir haben twitter diskussionen und so
weiter und so fort
das sind alles jetzt digitale virtuelle
realitäten die nicht mehr direkt
physisch vermittelt sind wie es zb
geldscheine sind durch dieses papier was
wir eben noch in der hand haben bitcoins
haben wir nicht in der hand das ist
jetzt der blaue party gut aus diesem
online rollenspiel runes kay er ist gar
nicht sonderlich anschaulich er ist
nicht besonders schöne es eigentlich
fast schon so eine art ja wie soll man
es sagen soll persiflage oder so eine
art ja eine art abkürzung das ist aber
jetzt kein grund ihn weniger realität
zuzusprechen
dieser gegenstand der blaue party und
die existiert in diesem online
rollenspiel nur ganz wenige male und
deswegen ist er so begehrt und nutzer
sind bereit dafür 1400 dollar zu
bezahlen das heißt der wert kommt
irgendwie zu obwohl er nicht die hand zu
nehmen ist obwohl man ihnen sie nicht
physisch aufsetzen kann
man kann sich aber virtuell auf setzt
nämlich auf sein avatar und das halte
ich für einen paradigmatischen fall von
virtueller realität der hat keine
räumliche ausdehnung hat aber eine
funktion und die funktion verleiht ihm
realität im virtuellen raum und auch
seine regiert hat seine relation zu
anderen gegenständen in dieser
virtuellen gemeinschaft so also dass der
blaue party hut 2680 dollar jetzt gehen
wir auf realität
virtualität simulation fiktion und
illusion kommen jetzt zu sprechen
was hat es damit auf sich wir müssen
virtuelle realität unterscheiden von
diesen formen von von funktionen von
phänomenen die wir im alltag auch
antreffen
wir müssen unterscheiden simulierte
versus virtuelle gegenstände also
simulierte gegenstände die sind von
ihrem realen vorbild abhängig und
besitzen keine eigenständige sach
haltige realität und kausalität sie sind
in sich abgeschlossen wie zb
einzelspieler computerspiele
einzelspiele computerspiele halte ich
nicht für virtuelle realitäten sei nur
für simulation virtuelle gegenstände
hingegen realisieren ihre vorbilder also
die physische welt häufig auf eine
andere weise sind nicht mehr davon in
ihrer und theologie abhängig so
entfalten eine eigene autonome
kausalität sind prinzipiell offen und
inter subjektiv zugänglich wie zb
bitcoins bitcoins sind für mich auch ein
paradigma tischer fall von virtualität
jetzt müssen wir noch illusorisch von
fiktiven gegenständen der scheiben
fiktive gegenstände benötigen keine
referenz auf ein reales vorbild also wie
es simulationen haben sind nicht
eindeutig und durchgängig bestimmt sind
konstrukte der fantasie zb hamlet
illusorische gegenstände referieren auf
eine falsche art und weise auf ein
reales vorbild zb die fata morgana und
jetzt ergibt sich so ein zusammenhang
man kann sagen virtuelle realität
besitzen ein simulant tief und einen
fiktionalen aspekt simulation sofern als
virtuelle virtuelle realitäten das
erreichen wollen was wir häufig in der
physischen realität erzielen das aber so
machen dass es mit der physischen
realität gar nichts mehr direkt
unbedingt zu tun haben muss
ja und das ist dann der fiktionale
aspekte dazu kommen es ist trotzdem von
simulationen fiktion unterschieden eben
dadurch dass eine realität ist eine
eigene kausale kraft hat sie sind
genauso real für die realität
wie es physikalische realitäten sind nur
eben auf eine andere weise virtuell
betreten geräuschen einer anderen raume
zeit logik als die physikalische
realität und jetzt kommen eben auch
gleich auf den punkt meines vortrags und
sie verhalten sich so zur sie erzeugen
physikalischen realität der server und
der computer und der der ganzen strom
durchfuhr usw
die mentale phänomene zum sie erzeugen
gehirn ich sehe da nicht ganz große
analogie also die virtuelle digitale
realität die verhält sich zu den
computern die sie erzeugt wie unsere
gedanken zum gehirn was auf unsere
gedanken erzeugt aber nicht dasselbe
sind
jetzt möchte ich ihren vorschlags
unterscheidung bringen also wir haben
realität können wir unterscheiden
physikalisch momentan und virtuell wir
können auch noch weitere realitäten
annehmen wie zb zahlen aber das möchte
ich jetzt mal auf drei begrenzt lassen
und wir haben eine realität die wir
unterscheiden können fiktion
simulationen illusion
es soll jetzt nicht heißen dass
simulation auch auf uns nicht wie wirken
können psychologisch aber diese wirkung
ist jetzt nicht objektiv die ist nur für
das jeweilige objekt zu die realität
wenn sie virtuell ist hat eine form von
objektivität die sie verbirgt
jetzt komme ich zur raum logik der
virtuellen realität ich verstehe raum
allgemein als offenheit oder möglichkeit
für physische oder auch virtuelle
wirksamkeit als es diese offenheit und
auch diese ermöglichung raum raumzeit
spielen im bereich der digitalen
virtuellen realität eine andere rolle
als in der physikalischen realität und
wie genau die ist jetzt der raum zu
bestimmen virtuelle objekte sind orts
los dabei aber von überall und jederzeit
zugänglich
man könnte auch sagen kubik wie teer wir
hatten gestern gehört diesen vortrag zum
thema gedanken palast dann mache ich
dann auch oben rechts ein link hinein
der schon auf youtube der hatte das auch
so dargestellt dass virtuelle
irgendwie utopisch sind ich möchte sie
lieber ubiquitär nennen wenn sie eine
form der virtuellen realität sind
im unterschied zum gedanken palast der
häufig nur für das jeweilige subjekt
gilt sind virtuelle räume wenn sie zb
durch das internet realisiert sind für
viele subjekte zugänglich und zwar auf
eine objektive art virtuelle objekte
stehen in relationen der vernetzung man
könnte auch sagen inter objektivität
nicht nur inter subjektivität diese
vernetzung sind als relation nicht starr
zu einem permanenten wandel unterworfen
und die kohärente und vernetzte das netz
ist desto stabiler ist es dass es auch
so meine antwort auf die gestrige frage
kann denn so ein gedanke na lassen auch
mal einstürzen ich würde sagen ja er
stürzt dann ein wäre nicht kohärent
genug ist also wenn die verschiedenen
gegenstände oder inhalte werden die sich
zu sehr widersprechen und nicht gut
ineinander gefügt sind und je besser die
vernetzung stattfindet in einem solchen
virtuellen raum wie zb kaum noch drauf
dem einem internet einem intranets desto
stabiler ist
es komme ich zur didaktik des virtuellen
raumes
meine these ist dass das internet ein
paradigma paradigmatische fall des
virtuellen raumes ist es ist keine bloße
spielerei auch in der didaktik obwohl
gamestation auch didaktik didaktisch
relevant ist es erlaubt die anbindung
integration verschiedener medien zu
einem verbindlichen lärm kontext und
könnte auch sagen über medium das inhalt
ist ein charismatischer virtueller leer
und lernen durch das internet wird
lernen und lehren nicht simuliert sind
es energien neue formen des lernens und
lehrens die verschiedenen lerntypen
gleichermaßen ansprechen das heißt jetzt
nicht dass wir uns dabei orientieren
können an dem herkömmlichen raum der
physischen raum dass wir zum beispiel
irgendwelche bilder verbänden den raum
regen mit bildern und so weiter aber wir
bekommen durch die anderen raum und zeit
logik neu formen des lernens
es werden damit in letzter konsequenz
auch läufer des denkens kultiviert im
virtuellen der und lernraum
die wesentlich mit der vernetzung
zusammenhängen als mit diesem netz
diesen über text der den virtuellen raum
auszeichnen
wie ich schon sagte das internet ist ein
paradigma der virtualität es ist zu
einem grundbedürfnis wie wasser strom
und wärme geworden das werden sie dann
merken wenn da ihn einmal ein tag lang
das internet ausfällt wie zb jetzt
während dieses impostors wenn jetzt hier
das internet ausfallen würde dann wäre
das für mich momentan schlimmer als wenn
hier die heizung oder was auch immer
jetzt ausgehen würde
es ist ein bestandteil geworden ist aber
nicht nur ein medium sondern es ist der
raum der medialität also es ist das
worin sich erst medialität wirklich
vollziehen kann
deswegen ist das internet ein raum der
virtualität in dem sich virtuelle
realität erreichen kann
so jetzt muss man jetzt diesen
virtuellen deren leeren raum bestimmen
er ist nicht durch linearität
ausgezeichnet sondern durch nicht
realität und zwar das hypertext ist als
das eines verwaltungssystems sagen ein
netz an dem lehrende und lernende
gemeinsam weiter spielen und einen
leeren lernen kann dicht oder nur lose
gestrickt sein er kann auch instabil
sein wenn er nicht kohärent ist als wenn
die inhalte sich widersprechenden sind
hier auf die adäquate weise miteinander
in verbindung gesetzt werden
wer nicht korrekt ist der virtuelle
lehrern lernraum ermöglicht es mentale
gehalt wie gedanke gedanken auf eine
besondere weise zu externalisierung die
nicht mehr allein an dass sie erzeugen
das objekt gefunden
vielmehr entsteht ein gedanken raum und
kontext in welchen sich lehrende und
lernende es objekte einschalten können
gelernt werden kontext erweist sich
damit als eine netzstruktur die immer
weiter entwickelt werden kann unabhängig
vom träger der gedanken
das ist als auch ein wichtiger punkt
dass es losgelöst wird vom subjekt der
inhalte hin zu seiner form von trans
objektivität gedanken werden nicht mehr
an das objekt gebunden sind sie werden
externalisierung in diesen virtuellen
raum und können miteinander in
verbindung gesetzt werden so als wäre es
ein
große subjekt was sie denken würde nicht
mehr nur ein individuum jetzt gebannt
bindungs beispiele noch zum schluss
wie kann man sich das vorstellen das ist
jetzt ganz banal man kann ein intranet
erstellen
in einem seminar was eben dem seminar
thema jetzt gewidmet ist welches dann
aber wiederum offen ist für die
anbindung an größere wissensnetz wie zum
beispiel wikipedia
das kann man einfach machen indem man
das internet verlinkt mit dem jeweiligen
wikipedia-eintrag und das aber auch
selbst dann weiter bestückt werden kann
durch die teilnehmer des seminars an
weiteren punkt den ich sehr wichtig
finde im virtuellen raum des internet
assist youtube und zwar deswegen ist nur
ein beispiel man kann auch noch andere
videoportale nennen ich halte aber
youtube momentan für das ist und zwar
deswegen weil es die unterscheidung
zwischen produzent dem lehrenden und dem
rezitieren dem lernenden immer mehr
aufhebt im bei youtube werden
rezipienten mit zu produzenten in dem
sie eben videos kommentieren indem sie
sie verlinken
indem sie auch wünsche äußern was jetzt
wieder aufgenommen wird also wenn auch
nicht die unterscheidung ganz aufgehoben
wird sie wird auf jeden fall fließen und
das glaube ich trifft dann auch das
verhältnis von lehrenden und lernenden
zu
schließlich halte ich es für ein gutes
beispiel für virtuelle für die nutzung
virtueller lernräume und leerräume weil
sie diese lehrern deren räume mobil
flexible öffnen und dem ubiquitären
status dieser virtuellen gegenständen
noch gerechter werden ich habe es eben
immer bei mir diesen lehr und lern haben
ich kann mich immer war nicht will
in diesen lehrern werden raum begeben
und ihnen zb nicht gebunden an meinen
stationären pc der dann wiederum an
einen physischen ort geboten ist ich
habe es immer bei mir also das seminar
für die hosentasche
das scheint mir auch noch wichtiger
punkt zu sein abschließend möchte ich
ihnen ein beispiel aufzeigen aus meiner
praxis diese viel okas teppich erstellt
haben in der sie wenn sie mal genau
hinschauen sehen hier gibt es dann
verschiedene symbole
das bedeutet ein wiki eintrag in diesem
internets der dann wiederum mit dem mit
wikipedia verknüpft ist und ihr dieses
symbol hier unten ist ein link weil man
verlinkt auch auf andere inhalte die
damit zusammenhängen so hat man ein ganz
dichtes netz wenn man sich daran
beteiligt und es als seminarteilnehmer
weiterspielen